[Musik]
bist du schon fertig ich gehe morgen die
druckereien gegenangebot machen zu
lassen
prima dann kann es ab morgen wieder
putzen dieser kann man ja in diesem jahr
nicht rechnen nun habt ihr euch immer
noch nicht versöhnen nico das ist ja
schön jetzt sind alle zusammen
dann kann ich den vorschlag machen ich
muss deutsch lernen wunderbar hier geht
gleich einer in die luft
wie ist denn dein vorschlag also
offensichtlich hat niemand zeit
führungsarbeit zumindest nicht alle
gleich viel
ich finde wir sollten uns einen
saugroboter kaufen um uns die arbeit zu
sparen
einen sack roboter ja das war wahnsinnig
teuer aber wir gehen den preis durch
vier teilen
ich finde wir sollten investieren damit
die stimmung wieder besser wird also ich
finde wir haben hier schon genug frau
bei der wg es reicht und das mit dem
saugroboter ist eine traube idee du hast
ja noch nicht mal angeschaut dann macht
doch bitte einen besseren vorschlag
junge frau mein vorschlag ist dass ich
jetzt das bad putzen und die küche okay
sind wir den offen für eine diskussion
überhaupt roboter
jemanden